Kevin James awesome and funny a movie
about animals that can talk less you
know not as zookeeper so zookeepers the
story of Kevin James who was a zookeeper
his girlfriend Leslie Bibb dumped him
five years ago when he tried to propose
to her then she shows up five years
later with her new boyfriend Joe Rokan
from Fear Factor and since when you date
women they put a chip in your brain in
which they can go away and come back
five years later and activate that chip
and you're just like you're there for
him all over again yeah it sucks he
wants to get her back only problem is
he's not a confident guy but wait
there's a catch animals can talk you
know like Brave Little Toaster and [ __ ]
actually I'm gonna go ahead and say Toy
Story on that one I don't know why I
pulled off the Brave Little Toaster that
was weird and so they're gonna teach him
how to be confident and an alpha male I
mean he has to learn his lesson as to
what love really is and whatnot because
Leslie bit it's like such a [ __ ] hot
yes no doubt but a gold-digging [ __ ]
yes I should probably watch my language
in these kids movie reviews gold-digging
[ __ ] I apologize yeah when I first saw
the teaser trailer to this movie I was
like Kevin James what are you doing but
I saw the full-length trailer and I was
like alright this might actually be
funny you know dating rituals that
people have or the same mistake primal
instincts and alpha male [ __ ] you know
that could be funny but after actually
watching the movie I'm more like Kevin
James what are you doing personally I
think Kevin James is hilarious I think
he's a comic genius and you can see he
really tries to give it his all just to
save this movie but it's a movie about
animals that can talk right there it
starts out a few notches below I think
honestly studio execs alike you know
we're a little under financially we got
to make this movie good but let me stop
you right there
it's about animals that can talk I mean
really are you sweating it that much
winning yeah to all the studio execs
that are watching this animals that can
talk automatic couple notches down
here's what I think was wrong with the
movie the concept premise and most of
the humorous for like five year-olds but
five year-olds aren't gonna care because
it's about a guy who's trying to get his
girl back and girls have like cooties to
them and then the adult humour kicks in
but adults aren't gonna care about the
movie because it's a premise that's for
five-year-old so it really doesn't
appeal to anybody it does stuff like the
wolf tells them a right piss on your
territory mark your territory pheromones
and all that good stuff alright now
you're a man I just do the Pope thing
that was weird very next scene he's in a
nice restaurant he's pissing on the
plant in the lobby I just don't think he
would do that I think he'd be like yeah
no I make it subtle like I'll piss
a car or something no middle of the
lobby in front of everybody a couple of
the animals that likes like Sylvester
Stallone plays a lion Nick Nolte places
gorilla he's the coolest part then there
was a monkey that kind of sounded like
Gilbert Godfried with cerebral palsy
guys I can describe it watch the trailer
you'll see as the Kevin James fan I
wanted to like the movie Kevin James was
funny but the rest of the movie was
garbage I don't know who Kevin James his
agent is but whoever he is he should be
kicked in the bag so I got to say
zookeeper is [ __ ] it's kind of like
liking chocolate I love chocolate but if
someone puts chocolate into like a bunch
of steaming mushrooms I ain't eat in the
chocolate case in point if you're a
Kevin James fan don't watch this movie
just because Kevin James is in it cuz it
makes no difference so just skip it no
need just watch King of Queens there's
like nine years of the show out there
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more one thing is for sure
the chick from King of Queens Leslie
Bibb and rosario Dawson yeah the skinny
things not working for me anymore
time to get some diabeetus